Transcriber: Hager Elbadawy
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
السلام عليكم ورحمة الله وبركاته
أول شيء أهلًا وسهلًا بكم جميعًا
وشكرًا على تواجدكم اليوم معنا
لكي تشاركونا هذه التجربة العجيبة،
تجربة (TEDx)
قبل أن أبدأ في موضوعي،
أريد أن أتحدث قليلًا عن التجارب.
نحن في حياتنا دائمًا،
أربع وعشرين ساعة من يومنا نجرب
تجارب أحيانًا تكون صغيرة
وأحيانًا تكون كبيرة نوعًا ما.
فمثلًا عندما أنام اليوم الساعة الثامنة
وغدًا أنام عند الحادية عشر
قمت اليوم بتجربة النوم في الثامنة،
ورأيت كيف سيكون حالي بعدما أفيق،
وكذلك عند الساعة الحادية عشر
تجربة مختلفة
أيضًا عندما نقوم بتجربة مطاعم
ولكن هذه تجارب بسيطة، حتى أنه بإمكاننا
مشاركتها، وقد تكون مفيدة.
لكن أحيانًا نمر بتجارب في حياتنا،
ندخل فيها بنسخة ونخرج بنسخة مختلفة تمامًا.
وعندما أقول نسخة مختلفة لا يعني بالضرورة
أن أكون أنا كحليمة تغيرت بالكامل،
لا، ولكن دعونا نقول هنالك
جزء مهم من كياني
أصبح أكثر وضوحًا.
لأن نحن الأصل والحقيقة لن تكون واحدة،
غالبًا مغطاة فقط بأقنعة
وصناديق دخلنا فيها.
يمكن لهذه التجارب أن تنتشلنا من هناك
وتقربنا من حقيقتنا أكثر.
وهذه هي التجارب التي تستحق
أن نتحدث عنها حقًا وننشرها،
لأنه لو لم نتحدث عن تجاربنا
سيقل مستوى المعرفة في هذا العالم،
لأن مستوى المعرفة يرتفع
كلما ارتفع حديثنا عن تجاربنا.
تجربتي التي أعتقد
أنها تستحق أن أتحدث عنها،
هي مسيرتي في الدراسة الجامعية .
لقد درست ثلاثة تخصصات
أمضيت في دراستي الجامعية
تقريبًا من سبع ونصف إلى ثمانِ سنوات،
أمضيت بعض الوقت في كلية
العلوم وقد لا يُحسب، لأنه كان بضع أسابيع.
وبعدها إننقلت لكلية الطب.
درست لمدة أربع سنوات في كلية الطب،
ثم فجأة قررت أن أتجه لتخصص آخر
وإنتقلت لكلية الصيدلة.
لقد لقبوني بابن بطوطة لهذا الأمر.
ما الذي جعلني أعيش كل هذه السنوات،
وأدرس كل تلك التخصصات.
عندما بدأت أدرس لأول مرة كان هدفي مختلفًا،
كبرت وتعلمت وتغير هدفي.
أصبحت أعرف نفسي أكثر، وأردت أن أجرب.
ولقد كان الأمر شاقًا بالنسبة لي
أن أتخذ هذا القرار
بعدما درست أربع سنوات بأكملهم،
وليس في أي تخصص،
تخصص الطب عظيم في النهاية.
وقد سمعت هذه الجملة كثيرًا:
“حليمة، كيف تركتِ الطب؟“.
كان الأمر صعبًا بالنسبة للمجتمع.
متى كان الوقت أو لحظة الإلهام
التي أتخذت فيها قراري؟
هذا هو الوقت الذي يجب أن أتخلص فيه
من المكان الذي لا يشبهني،
وأنتقل لأرى الحياة والعالم.
أتذكر أنني كنت في آخر سنة في الطب،
قبل الإنتقال لمرحلة أخرى مختلفة.
في آخر فصل كنت جالسة
في ساحة الانتظار بالخارج.
ثم...
وفجأة أحسست بضيق بداخلي.
هل ترون المفتاح والقفل
بمعنى أن المفتاح يجب أن يتناسب مع القفل.
هكذا، يجب أن يناسب هذا ذاك.
لقد بدأت أشعر أن كأن هذا أنا وهذا الكرسي
لا يسعني هناك سعه داخلي أريد اخراجها.
أريد إخراجها ولكن لا أعرف كيف
لأن المكان لا يسعني.
وأحسست فجأة وقتها -وهذا ليس تعبير مجازي-
أن كأن جدران ساحة الانتظار تلك
تضغط علي لدرجة أنني شعرت بألم هنا
في أطرافي كأنني أحاول أن أضغط
نفسي في مكانٍ لا يناسبني.
ولهذا السبب كنت أحاول إزالة أجزاء من نفسي
جزء يمثل حليمة الحقيقية جزء من كيان حليمة
لأنه كأنني أحاول أن أتناسب
مع مكان لا يمثلني،
أي أن المفتاح والقفل غير متطابقين
كأنني أحاول نحته ليتطابق، فعندما شعرت بهذا
اتصلت بالسائقة وأخبرتها أن تأتي لتقلني.
قالت لي: “لماذا يا حليمة، مازال هناك
محاضرات حسب الجدول الذي معي؟”
فقلت: “لا أريد البقاء هنا.”
وذهبت عند التسجيل والقبول وسألتهم:
“لو قررت ترك هذا التخصص ماذا سيحدث
هل يمكن أن أدرس تخصص آخر، هل سيسمحوا لي؟”
فقالوا لي: “على حسب الكليات التي
ستستقبلك، وحسب الوزارة”
وقتها كان أهم شيء يجب أن يحدث
أن أكون في مجال وأحصل على شهادة.
ذهبت إلى هناك وسحبت أوراقي في نفس اليوم،
ثم رحلت، وأنهيت الإجراءات بعد يومين.
عشت تلك المرحلة “أين أذهب الآن؟
ماذا يحدث في حياتي؟”
لا أعرف، كنت متجهه للمجهول فعليًا.
ما الذي كان يمنعي قبل هذه المرحلة
التي قلت فيها “غايته”.
كان هناك نقطتان تمنعانني،
وهما الأكبر: خوفي، وبرمجيات عقلي.
خوفي من نفسي،
كنت أخاف أن تفقد حليمة قيمتها.
كنت أعتقد أن قيمتي تنبع من
مسمى طبيبة الخاص بي
أي أن حليمة ستصبح طبيبة
إذًا قيمتها في هذا المسمى.
نسيت أنني كجسد وروح من صنع الله بالأساس
إذًا أنا إنسانه عظيمة
بغض النظر عن أي شيء آخر.
النقطة الثانية البرمجات،
أنني كنت مبرمجة منذ الصغر
المرأة الطبيبة، أن الفتاة المجتهدة
في المدرسة تصبح طبيبة.
وذلك أنساني أن هناك أشياء أخرى
وعالم متسع يمكن أن يشبهني.
عندما قلت غايته وانتقلت للمرحله التي
اختار فيها نفسي،
كنت قد قررت أن أدرس الصيدلة في الحقيقة.
لكن بطريقة أو بأخرى كان هناك صوت بداخلي
يقول لي يا حليمة أدرسي الصيدلة أنت تشعرين
أنها لا تشبهك كتخصص ولكن أدرسيها.
وقد كنت محقة لأنني فعليًا
لم أجد ذاتي في الصيدلة
لقد تخرجت كصيدلانية، لم تكن الصيدلة تشبهني
ولكنني وجدت الأبواب والفرص
عندما كنت أدرس الصيدلة.
كأنها كانت الطريق، ولماذا أصبحت الطريق
لأنني قررت حينها أختيار نفسي.
واختار خياري حتى لو لم يكن منطقيًا للعالم
أو حتى لنفسي
هنا قررت أن أسمع صوتي الداخلي واختار بنفسي
ولا أسمح لأي أحد أن يختار لي.
ما تغير بعد هذه المرحلة،
التي اخترت فيها نفسي، خمسة أشياء تقريبًا:
أول شيء صحتي، الشكل الخارجي،
الأهداف، الفرص والجانب الروحي.
في البداية،
الشكل الخارجي، كان هناك شيء غريب يحدث
عندما أذهب للأماكن العامة،
كان الناس يقولون: “أيعقل؟
هل أنتِ حليمة، لم نعرفكِ”
لا أعتقد أن شكلي تغير ولكن من الممكن
أن مشاعري من الداخل
وصحتي الخارجية هي التي غيرت شكلي
فأصبح الناس يروني بطريقة مختلفة.
من ناحية الصحة، كنت أعاني
من مشاكل في الجهاز الهضمي والقولون.
كنت أعاني من مشاكل في المفاصل
وبدأت كلها تتلاشى تقريبًا.
الشيء الثالث والأهم وهو الجانب الروحي،
وصلت لمرحلة سلام.
أصبحت أكثر قدرة على عيش الحياة
ورؤيتها من منظور آخر.
وقادرة على الإقتناص وهذا هو الشيء الخامس،
الرابع، أكون قادرة على اقتناص الفرص
واقتناصي للفرص
قد سهل لي عملية وصولي للأهداف.
وقد ساعدني كل ذلك على الوصول
لمرحلة اكتشف فيها نفسي.
وبعدما اكتشفت فيها نفسي،
أصبحت الحياة تساعدني
على أن اكتشف وأعيش التجارب
بطريقة مختلفة وتشبهني أكثر.
بعدما انتهيت من هذه التجربة.
تركزت في حياتي أربع مبادئ تقريبًا،
أصبحت أساسية، أعيش وأسير بها.
أولًا: ما يعتقده عنك الآخرون ليس أنت.
ثانيًا: مقياس الفشل والنجاح
يختلف من شخص لآخر حسب
قيمه ومبادئه.
وآخر نقطة وهي الأهم:
لا يهم أن تختار بشكل صحيح
ولكن المهم أن تكون أنت من يختار.
شكرًا جزيلًا
(تصفيق)